This is one of the great
stories of Ma'am timed and it's,
it's not,
this isn't the only variant of this story.
There's many variants of it,
but,
but this variant is useful for,
for our purposes.
That's a story I stumbled
across a long time ago.
Yeah.
I'm going to tell you the second story
first because I don't have the energy to
tell you the first story.
So this is a story that the ancient
Egyptians predicated their society on.
And to understand this story,
the first thing you have to know
is what the characters were in.
These characters were gods.
There's four of them.
Although the Egyptians had
far more than four gods.
You might think of these
as the central gods.
And you might think,
what is the central God?
And then you might think,
well,
imagine that the gods compete for
dominance across time and people's
imaginations and some gods win.
And they occupied the primary position
of dominance in the hierarchy,
in the dominance hierarchy of gods.
And those are ideals and ideals compete
across time for dominance and their
embodied.
And so when diverse tribal
people come together,
they throw all their gods into the ring
and they fight across time and something
emerges as a victor,
and that's the emergence of
monotheism out of polytheism and it,
it parallels the development
of our unified morality
in within each of us as we
develop across time
and the,
the god that emerges as dominant across
time bears a substantial represent a
substantial
resemblance.
Imagine you have a set of gods in this
locale that are competing across time and
something emerges as dominant.
And then over here you have another set
of gods that compete across time for
dominance and something emerges.
You'll see major commonalities
across the two things that emerge.
And the reason for that
is because the emergent,
the process of emergence that gives
rise to both of them is similar in both
situations.
And that's part of what accounts for the
cross cultural similarity of high order
religious ideas.
All right?
Anyways,
you need to know the characters.
Oh,
Cyrus Cyrus is the old king.
He's Dumbledore.
For all intents and purposes,
he's the old king.
He's the,
he's the,
the spirit that established
the Egyptian state.
When he was young,
he was a great hero.
But now he's old and he's Wilf,
he's archaic and he's willfully blind.
That's,
oh Cyrus.
He has a brother,
Seth.
Seth is set and set is Satan because the
word Satan comes from the word Seth and
set via the Coptic Christians.
So,
so,
so he's a precursor to the western idea.
Satan,
you have isis.
Isis is queen of the underworld and
Isis was the goddess of a religious
structure that
okay
prevailed across thousands
and thousands of years.
Isis and you have Horace.
Horace is a Falcon and the Egyptian I,
everyone's knows that I write
the eye with the open pupil.
That's Horace.
And Horace is a fall can because
falcons can see way better.
They can see better than us.
They can see better than anything
else except for perhaps eagles.
And they fly above everything
is a zoo in the lion.
King is Horace,
right.
And Move Fossa is,
oh,
Cyrus and scar is Seth
and there's no specific
representation of Isis.
But the closest there is in that story
is probably the queen of the hyenas.
That's played by a WHO's the actress?
Um hmm.
Yes.
Whoopi Goldberg.
That's right.
Because she,
they inhabit,
she's like the queen of the underworld,
right?
She's the queen of the hyenas
that live out among the death.
But okay.
Anyways,
Seth.
Oh,
Cyrus.
Seth,
are you,
so send Horace,
here's how the story goes.
Well,
serious is a great king.
He established the Egyptian state.
You could think about him
as the embodiment of the,
of Egyptian custom and tradition.
You could think about him as the
thing that the pyramid represents.
All right?
But he was great when he was young,
but he's not young anymore.
He's old and he's willfully blind.
And what that means is that he
doesn't see what he could see.
He refuses to see what he could see.
Why is ocirus old and willfully blind?
Because that's what culture is.
It's a paternal spirit that's
old and willfully blind.
And it's always that way,
always that way.
And the reason for that is because
it's a construction of the dad.
The Dad aren't alive.
They can't,
so they're out of date and they can't
update themselves anymore and you inhabit
their corpse.
And that's actually what happens in an
earlier story that I'll tell you next
week.
[inaudible] early Mesopotamian gods
inhabited the corpse of their father,
roughly speaking anyway,
so,
oh,
Cyrus was great and when he was young,
but he hasn't young anymore.
He's old and he's willfully blind.
He won't look where he
knows he should look.
He doesn't have the energy or
maybe he doesn't have the spirit.
His brother Seth is
not a good guy and was,
Cyrus knows it,
but he underestimates his malevolence
and power and so Seth wants to rule the
kingdom.
So what does that mean?
It's easy.
Every stable society is,
is threatened by willful
blindness and malevolence always.
Every bureaucracy has that proclivity
to stagnate and to become blind.
That's why corporations die all the time.
That's why a fortune 500
company only lasts 30 years.
It's why we have to have elections.
It's to stop the Dad from
staying control for too long.
Seth,
oh,
Cyrus turns a blind eye to Seth.
Seth is happy about that.
Same thing happens in the lion king,
roughly speaking.
Seth one day waits for a Cyrus
to make a mistake and to be weak,
and he attacks him and he chops them
up into pieces and he distributes the
pieces across the entire Egyptian state.
In fact,
the Egyptians regarded their
provinces as pieces of,
oh,
Cyrus's body.
Okay,
so now you can't kill our
Cyrus because he's a god.
And why is he god a God?
Because he represents the spirit of
structure and there's always structure.
It can't be destroyed.
It always reconstitutes itself.
It can be hurt and broken into pieces,
which is exactly what happens to a Cyrus.
Things fall apart.
Why?
Because they get old and because
malevolence undermines them.
That's what the Egyptians
were trying to sort it out.
Okay.
So Seth distributors though,
Cyrus all over Egypt,
so he can't get himself back together.
Right?
Things fall apart and they
can't be brought back together.
But the spirit of,
Oh,
Sarah's still lives in the pieces.
So what happens?
Orders demolished.
What would you expect?
Chaos emerges.
That's isis.
Isis as queen of the underworld.
She's well Cyrus's wife order and chaos.
Just like the Yin and
the Yang order collapses.
Up comes the queen of the underworld.
She's looking for order.
Chaos cries out for order.
She goes all around
Egypt trying to put ice.
So Cyrus back together.
It's a state of chaos.
She finds this Fellas,
she makes herself pregnant with it.
And what does that mean?
Well,
it means it's like it's like Japan.
No,
in the belly of the whale.
That thing has the
potential to reemerge this,
the thing that collapses into its pieces,
it's still alive.
It,
it can unite with the chaos
and produce something new.
That's the story of the dissolution
of structure into chaos.
And then it's reverification.
Isis makes herself pregnant.
She goes back down to the underworld.
She gives birth to Horace.
Horace is the Egyptian I,
he's the son of the great
father and the great mother.
He's a,
he's a messianic figure.
And in fact,
much of the mythology that described
Horace was extracted without much
modification and then attributed
to Christ very much maybe.
And you,
you can read about the parallels.
You can read about it online if you want.
There's any number of parallels.
And of course there is a methodology
that the Jews came out of Egypt and of
course the Christians
emerged from the juice.
And so there was a tremendous influence
of Egyptian thinking on the development
of these later ideas.
And you see pictures of Isis with Horace
on her lap that are virtually identical
in content and form to the later pictures
of Mary with the Intranet Christ.
But that's the holy mother
of God and the hero.
It's,
it's not a Christian motif.
It's far deeper than a Christian motif.
It's a human motif.
So Isis,
queen of the gives birth to Horace and
Horace grows up outside the kingdom.
Why?
In underworld?
Because that's what human beings do.
You're alienated from your culture always.
Why?
It's old and dead and corrupt.
And so that leaves you
growing up in chaos.
Uh,
what would you call alienated
from your fundamental culture?
That's the story of adolescence.
Horace grows up,
he can see that's what
differentiates them from old Cyrus.
That's why he's a falcon.
He goes and has a fight with Seth.
And now the difference between those
Cyrusone and Horace is that horse does not
or underestimates Seth.
He knows exactly what he's up against and
he goes and has a terrible battle with
him trying to get his kingdom back.
Something else that's echoed in
the lion king story and well,
Horace An and,
oh,
sorry,
Seth are fighting Seth
terrorists out one of his eyes.
Now,
why?
Because Seth is the
embodiment of destruction and
malevolence and no matter how
conscious you are,
if you encounter that even voluntarily,
the probability that it's going to damage
your consciousness is extraordinarily
high.
That's why people don't do it,
so the eyes torn out,
but Seth is defeated and Horace banishes
him to the nether regions of the
kingdom.
You can't kill him.
Why?
Because the malevolent,
destructive force,
the threatened states never dies.
It's always there.
You can only remove it temporarily.
Now Horace is King Pharaoh,
King God,
he's got his eye and so you think,
well,
he's going to just pop that back in his
hand and then he's going to be able to
lead.
He's going to be able to take his
place at the upper most pantheon,
pantheon of gods properly.
But that isn't what he does.
He takes his eye and he
goes back to the underworld,
just like Pinocchio,
going into the depths to rescue,
to pedal.
And down there is the spirit of all Cyrus,
who's,
who's extent as a kind of half dad ghost
and it gives us,
oh,
Cyrus's I
now,
we'll,
sorry,
Russ can see.
So what does that mean?
You go down into the chaotic
when threatened by malevolence,
even to the point of damage
to your consciousness.
You go down into the chaos and you find
the dead spirit of your tradition and
you give it vision and so provided
with vision or Cyrus regenerates.
And then it was Cyrus
and Horace go back up to,
to,
to the world linked
together and rule jointly.
And the Egyptians believed that the
Pharaoh who had an immortal spirit was the
embodiment of the conjunction
of Horace and or Cyrus.
And that's what gave him sovereignty.
And so you think about
how brilliant that is.
The Egyptians are trying to
puzzle out who should lead,
who should be feral and
what do you have to be?
If you're going to be pharaoh,
in order for things to work,
you have to be awake to malevolence
and chaos and you have to embody your
tradition and that puts you at the highest
pinnacle of the dominant structure.
It's,
and that's the same as,
it's the same thing.
It's the same thing as the battle between
the gods across centuries or Ian's and
the emergence of the highest possible
moral virtue as a consequence of that
competition.
It's the eye on the top of the pyramid,
right?
It's,
you know,
on the Washington monument there's
a cap on the Washington monument.
The top of the Washington
monument is a pyramid.
At the top of the pyramid is a cap.
It's made out of aluminum.
And the reason it's made out of
aluminum is because when they made the
Washington monument,
it was the most valuable metal known.
And so what does it mean?
It means there's a pyramid and
there's something up the top of it.
But the thing that's a tall at the top
of the pyramid isn't the same as the rest
of the pyramid.
That's the thing.
The pyramid exists.
There's a dominance hierarchy.
Something climbs up to the top,
but it's not just at
the top of one pyramid.
It's at the top of all of them.
The thing that rises to the top at any
given pyramid is the same thing that can
dominate all pyramids.
It isn't good enough to be the
best at a dominance hierarchy.
What do you want to be is the best
at the set of all possible dominance
hierarchies,
right?
And that's the thing that's
gold at the top of the pyramid.
And that's the eye.
That's what the Egyptians figured out.
And what does that mean?
It means the thing that puts
you at the top is attention,
pay attention,
keep your eyes open.
It's not the same as thinking.
It's not the same thing.
It's like watching.
And the thing about human
beings is we can see,
we can see better than any other
creature except birds of prey.
And so our capacity to see is in
fact what we use in the world.
Our brains are actually
organized around vision.
Unlike most animals,
their brains are organized around smell,
not us.
We can see we stand up,
right?
So we can see a long distance and in
our ability to see is what saves us and
what saves our communities.
And that's what these stories
are trying to portray.
Hey,
you might say,
well,
why didn't people just say so?
And the answer to that is
because they didn't know
it took a long time to
figure it out forever.
It's taken forever to figure it out.
It's,
it's part of what I hoped
when I wrote this book.
And,
and part of the reason that I'm teaching
it is because it seems to me that it
would be useful for everyone to actually
understand this instead of just having
it told as a story.
It's like,
that's great,
man.
Yes,
you need the story,
but why not also just understand it.
So
muscle,
that's what we're trying to do.
We're trying to understand this
so.